my favorite activity three two one
[Music]
black magic they make davinci resolve da
vinci is a free color grading program it
works really well
one of the guys there saw our star wars
drone video you guys need
some sick cameras for putting on drones
they have sent us
a black magic micro cinema camera
basically a little action camera so
think of like
a gopro but a lot more cinematic yeah
look how tiny this guy is wow that's
really cool actually
dude this is like maximum efficiency of
technology right here sweet i can't wait
to fire this up let's get some test
images
a few months ago i was opening the door
to our studio and wren was on the other
side
and he fired a nerf gun at me and as
that dart came flying towards my face i
thought
i can do this i can be a total badass
and i reached up and snatched that nerf
dart
out of the air before it hit me in the
eye i'm wondering
is that something that's really easy to
do or is it actually almost impossible
do we all have secret ninja skills
we're gonna go up on the roof and we're
gonna shoot nerf guns at each other's
faces and see if we have the ability to
snatch nerf darts out of the air let's
go
all right try to shoot me in the face
my pleasure
this gun all sucks
three two one
[Music]
you know the darts even hit me so i
wouldn't have had to catch them
i just being efficient with my use of
energy pro would have caught them
three two one the [ __ ] is that
three two one what the hell dude
three two one
i didn't even have to move my hand i
just had to close it no
no
[Music]
arrows ain't no thang
three two one
i'm going for four for four
that one was a fastball call me three
four for short
34. i have been tasked with putting
together
this black magic micro cinema camera i'm
putting it together because niko asked
me to
i think i just needed to have a job
assigned to me oh
there's a light you can see the sensor
we need to get
a monitor for this
there it goes i said we put a lens on
the camera this is an adapter
you line up the red dots there we go
it is this is hilarious
this is called an israeli arm i always
do things the most efficient way
[Music]
it's literally all right grab an arrow
like this supplies by
three two one
yeah so right here is back from vietnam
finally wow so everyone's caught narrow
yep i have to not fail here just walking
along minding my own business
but something red pops out
wren's dead all right okay i'm gonna
shoot you nico
all right let's do this peter thanks
[Music]
you